Even though dad and I love having fun,...
Hello, Mr. Lee.
...he is always busy with his work.
As a big guy, dad  is serious sometimes.
And even more...
Finish all your food.
Don't be picky about it.
He is kind of fierce.
Hey, don't always play games.
You guys are not kids anymore.
Dad always works too late to ensure that we have a better life.
So on this birthday, we wanted to do something special...
...to thank you for always being there for us.
You are our superhero, our shelter and protector.
We are able to thrive and grow because of you.
You have no superpowers, yet you always give us the best you can.
Hello, daddy.
I'll be home late.
Okay.
So you guys go ahead and meet without me.
Alright.
Happy birthday!
Dad, thanks for being our hero.
You are the greatest gift in our life.
We love you.